identities you've been doing identities
already you've done at this point the
course you've done tree garden ease of
what trig identities you've done some
identities with like definite integrals
when you don't even or the function that
kind of thing
you've done polynomial identities where
you compare one polynomial which should
be exactly the same as the other why
they tell presented in different form
now we're going to look at binomial
identities which is really short for
identities then involve the binomial
coefficients but that doesn't quite roll
the tongue as easily so when I say
binomial identities this is the kind of
stuff I mean now we've looked at these
simple ones before these all have names
because they're so important we're
actually gonna just to for the sake of
it remember how to do this one because
it's been a little while since you
looked at this this is really easy might
take let's say I've got two two and a
half lines recent and how would you go
about proving something like this just
like all identity proofs you've got to
start with one side which side would you
like me to start from to move the other
one just that with this one and go to
here or start with this one and go to
here I'd probably start with this one
and then go to key because I know what
the definition of that is nothing quite
it whereas I can probably work out what
that is but by the time I've done that I
might as well started from that side so
I'm gonna actually do this proof my hand
side I'll begin by just stating it and
then I'm going to expand that all in
terms of factorials or what have you so
let's just join it down first the
numerator is the easy bit can be careful
the denominator what's the first thing I
write and minus R factorial okay and
then rather than do the simplification
all in one hit right I'm gonna do it
with my subtract here you'll see it
comes every quickly right I'm gonna do
the whole substitution and then I'll do
all the simplification off because this
is a proof after all right I want to
show the logic so for a normal one right
we can quit this one it's n factorial on
R factorial n minus R factorial right so
you're gonna this take away this for the
second piece
the pot I'm trying to work out right now
so this time I need to do this take away
this let's write that down
that's the top part of the NCR right and
there's the bottom part at Oriel plaster
the whole thing but as soon as you've
written it down clearly you can see the
ends cancel the negatives cancel and
once you go left with is this okay
which of course is what we're creating
just a second ago so there's your result
okay now these pretty simple all you
really need to know is the definition of
what NCR was how to work with some
simple arithmetic sometimes you have to
be careful with factorials and so on but
that's basically you okay now this one
here I'm not going to rehearse the whole
proof for you but the principle works in
much the same way what do you think
should you start from the left hand side
or the right hand side right hand side
left hand sorry now in this case this is
just like with the trig identities where
sometimes it's like there isn't always
obviously one side that's simpler than
the other these are both kind of messy
in their own way I don't like this it's
not that obvious what's going to happen
out of that but then again this is like
a pair of fractions it's very unusual to
like how do I start with one fraction
and then in what way am I supposed to
break that up to get two so I'm just
going to show you really quickly you
don't don't worry about writing this
down I can put it up again in a second
if you like I chose to start from the
left-hand side and this is what my proof
look like okay so sigh we done left hand
side with the pair of fractions the
details are not important because you
can just crunch through them but you can
see I just evaluated what each of them
was and then I thought okay I'm going
where I'm headed it's a bit of a messy
fraction but at least it's one fraction
so if I'm reading two fractions into one
that my first task obviously is common
denominator right just like with any
other fractions so you can see what I'm
trying to do here can you see what I've
gone done from this line to this line on
the first fraction what am i done from
here to here I'm multiplied the
numerator denominator by our plus one do
you see why I did that because that R
plus one on the top will turn this guy
in
plus one factorial that will give me a
common denominator do you see that I
chose to also multiply this one by n
minus R and and - I do you see that that
turn this into n minus R or factorial
now I've got a common denominator I mean
you just have to be careful with your
algebra and out pops the result that you
needed okay I will point out it's still
not entirely hundreds in obvious because
you get to this spot right you do the
numerator and you're like but that that
denominator looks five what are you
gonna do with that you actually have to
make it a bit Messier to get to this
right do you see how this comes out of
this do you see it right so it's still
not as straightforward that's why I'm
not doing it with you right now because
not the emphasis but you can see the
skills that we're assessing with you
right so okay you know what NCR notation
is and you can work with it if you know
where you're supposed to be getting that
makes sense